hi there this is steve kaufman i want to
talk to you today about the the best way
to learn languages the best way
and the reason i'm doing that is because
uh someone brought to my attention
a lady
who has written a book called i think
language is music her name is susanna
ryski if i'm not mistaken
and i saw a video of her being
interviewed in english and spanish which
she speaks fluently and apparently and i
don't know that no doubt reason to doubt
her speaks seven languages fluently
and she says many things that i agree
with
about the importance of listening before
you
speak uh about the importance of getting
the language in you before you
try to spend too much time on grammar
she likes to listen to music
and she thinks that listening to music
and listening to songs is the key to
learning languages
something that i don't agree with
although i do agree with her
that there is a music to language and
when i learned chinese for example i
spent an awful lot of time listening to
comic dialogues in chinese because i
found that their intonation very
enchanting
now uh so i had a look at what susanna
had to say
then there was a gentleman who he styles
himself the monk of brooklyn or the
brooklyn monk who is a
martial arts expert and also a language
uh you know polyglot
and he came back and said no it's not
that easy you can't just listen to music
it takes a lot of hard work when i study
i work five six hours a day at my
language
which i once did too i did that once
when i was learning chinese
and that certainly can be effective
uh then i of course thought of my
friend benny who claims that the best
way to learn to speak is just to speak
from day one
uh i remember the video that i saw of
alex argelia's showing sort of a day in
the life of a polyglot
where he spends 15 minutes on
ancient greek half an hour
writing out russian another half an hour
and
korean
spends his whole day 15 minutes half an
hour on different languages
refreshing and and of course developing
new competence in those languages
um
someone also commented on my blog or i
think at the forum at link
that they were in a french class and the
teacher said they're not that the
students were not allowed to do anything
outside of the class because the teacher
wanted to control what they learned
so that's just to say that there are
many different approaches so oh and i
forgot moses
moses mccormick who
many of you may know and i've watched
many of his videos and has a very folksy
style and he's a very accomplished
uh polyglot seems to pick up languages
quite quickly
and he recommends an approach which you
can find if you google moses mccormick
but it does involve
learning certain key
uh phrases and key sort of trigger words
in a language
and i certainly believe that there's a
lot to that as well
uh luca
italian polyglot who uh he likes to
listen and
then uh i if i remember correctly he
will try to translate what he listened
to into italian and write it out
okay so
and of course my emphasis is a lot of
listening and reading focus on
vocabulary occasional grammar of you and
speak when you want to
so what is the best way to learn
languages
well in my opinion
first of all let me say that the
wonderful thing today
is that we have access by the internet
via youtube to all these different
people and their opinions
on what is the best way to learn
languages so if your teacher says you're
not allowed to do anything outside the
class you no longer have to listen to
the teacher you can get the advice of
alex argelias the brooklyn monk moses
mccormick me benny
whoever you want you can go looking for
content wherever you want you can more
or less do whatever you want so to that
extent the the control that the teacher
used to exercise
over your learning is basically gone so
it's basically up to the learner to take
advantage of that freedom
uh so
uh now you have the freedom so what is
the best way to learn
in my opinion the best way to learn is
whatever you like doing
okay it's that simple
if for example i would never do what
professor argelia's does i just couldn't
spend my day half an hour in this
language 20 on that language i have to
concentrate on one language i am trying
to take time away from my russian in
order to spend more time on korean i
find it very difficult to do
to me listening to songs doesn't do it
because my perspective is that language
learning is largely about vocabulary
songs do not have a lot of vocabulary
i've had my discussion with benny i
don't believe you can start talking
until you've got a lot of the language
in you
i also believe that that when you speak
depends on your situation your
opportunity your personal preference and
so forth
so
however
and the other thing too is i don't spend
a lot of time on on space repetition
systems a lot of people come at me how
can you deny the science behind space
repetition systems there is no science
if i don't like to spend my time doing
it
uh i do review flash cards and link and
i click on the audio to hear it and i'll
deliberately go into my vocabulary list
and pick out all the genitive case that
i've tagged in my link vocabulary and
review them and listen to them and i'll
go in and and review all of the
accusative or
verbs of motion things like that in
russian a very deliberate study of
specific things in flashcards with the
sound on the flashcards that we now have
but mostly i just like to listen and
read
and because i don't have to write an
exam because i'm not in a situation
where i have to speak every day my major
concern is understanding so today
someone sent me a video
in russian
of a debate between uh
i think his name is navalny
and uh who is a major critic of the
regime in russia of the corruption in
russia and the gentleman by the name of
uh yeah i think it's alexei navalny and
the other gentleman was evgeny fiodrov
who represented the dna racing party and
they had the debate and it was i could
understand it all i'm happy that to me
is my goal so what do you like to do and
what are your goals what are your needs
and and based on that you decide what's
going to work for you if you like what
you do you're going to end up spending
time doing it and all the time that you
spend with the language is good so if
someone says it you know comes up with a
very structured for example mnemonic
system and you associate words with
colors or flowers or images or someone
says you should write very early because
it's good for you it is good to write
but if you don't want to write you'll
end up not doing it if you like
listening to songs or we had keith in
japan who liked watching movies even
when he didn't understand them
if he spends a lot of time doing that
that's good for him
i've had many people tell me that they
they will uh have say spanish on in the
background at work there's many places
in the united states where there's
spanish radio so at work they'll have
spanish on the background and that they
claim that that helps them learn the
language and i am sure it does it's not
something that i would do
so
simply because i would find it a bit
distracting but i'm sure it's good for
you i'm sure it's good for you uh so all
i'm saying is that there are many many
different ways to learn the most
important thing is that you like what
you're doing now
typically those people who like certain
things will want to say that this is the
best way and i will quite frankly say
that because it works for me
but and that's how we develop link based
on what works for me now
uh people who
study the same way as i do who have the
same taste as i do the same preferences
the same interests and so forth or
similar
will likely or maybe they'll find ways
of using link that suits what they like
to do
uh but people who don't like doing that
won't be successful there so so it's
very important i think
i think we should we're all uh
fully justified whether it be
whoever you know to get on the internet
and say this is the best way because i
believe in it and it works for me and
for some people it'll work and other
people will say no it's got to be this
other way and and obviously getting back
to our brooklyn monk obviously if you
can spend five six seven hours a day
learning you'll do better than if you
only spend one hour a day but my belief
is that most people haven't got five six
hours a day
if they can at least discipline
themselves to spend one hour a day
mostly listening
uh to interesting things
while doing other tasks that that is at
least practical for most people to do
so but if they don't like listening then
that's not gonna work so so there you
have it the best way to learn languages
is whatever you like doing whatever gets
you spending time with the language and
whatever suits your particular situation
and needs
thank you for listening